Hollywood and the music world in
mourning over the shocking murder of
grammy-nominated rapper
Nipsey Hussle from Rihanna my spirit is
shaken by this from nipsey's friend
Kevin Hart who have always been a good
dude I'm so sorry see me on the street
[Music]
and this darkly ironic tweet from nipsey
himself having strong enemies is a
blessing came just thirty minutes before
he was gunned down in broad daylight
yesterday in the South LA neighborhood
where he grew up we last talked to
nipsey at the Grammys his album victory
lap songs from which have been streamed
almost 400 million times was nominated
we just excited I'm inspired obviously
you don't want to get back and make some
new music
nip sees longtime girlfriend actress
Lauren London is devastated their son
Kross is just 2 years old who was better
with Kross know I intend to inspire
people with my story today many stars
like Drake and Pharrell Williams were
calling attention to nipsey's good works
he was dedicated to making his Crenshaw
neighbourhood better opening several
stores and hiring locals to work in them
outside I was a little chaotic gang
culture was what was going on it was in
front of one of those stores marathon
clothing where hustle was murdered
[Music]